work life balance is an extremely
fraught topic in the startup community
some people argue that the only way to
succeed is to outwork your competition
while others insist that spending a
hundred hours a week coding for years on
end
will lead to burnout and sub-optimal
outcomes so who's right i'm john coogan
and here are my thoughts on work life
balance this topic is top of mind for me
because i just had my first child
it was a really amazing experience that
i would definitely recommend to anyone
who is on the fence about starting a
family
but it's definitely not easy in fact
supporting a family is so time consuming
that many people in the startup world
think you really shouldn't even try to
start a startup
if you're currently supporting a family
here's what paul graham had to say about
it
i wouldn't advise anyone with a family
to start a startup
i'm not saying it's a bad idea just that
i don't want to take responsibility for
advising it
i'm willing to take responsibility for
telling 22 year olds to start startups
so what if they fail they'll learn a lot
and that job at microsoft will still be
waiting for them if they need it
but i'm not prepared to cross moms and i
generally agree with that sentiment
a family is a ton of responsibility and
i can't imagine the stress of raising a
child while getting a startup off the
ground
fortunately for me i did exactly what pg
recommends
and started my first company when i was
22. i had zero responsibilities at that
time
and it was easy to sync over 100 hours a
week into coding and building products
at the early stage
now nearly 10 years later i feel like i
have things a bit more under control
that's not to say that startups are easy
by any means i'm constantly putting out
fires at my current startup lucy
but fortunately i have a great team of
co-founders and employees who can cover
for me
while in this early stage of parenting
it's very hard to create
size fits all startup advice and that's
certainly true here
the craziest refutation of the you have
to be young
to start a tech company has to be david
duffield who founded workday at the age
of 64.
before starting workday duff field had
founded peoplesoft in 1984
and was a huge name in the tech industry
still founding a tech company
when you're on the cusp of becoming a
senior citizen certainly takes guts
but it paid off massively workday is now
worth around 60 billion dollars
so what about the broader question of
work-life balance there have been a few
big debates about the topic throughout
the years
but one of my favorites involves jason
freed and keith rayboy
jason freed is the co-founder of
basecamp a workplace collaboration
company that
bucked the trend of raising massive vc
funding in favor of bootstrapping
over the past decade jason has written a
number of books on the topic of
work-life balance
and generally argues that success in
business does not require working to the
point of burnout
keith has a very different view of this
issue he's a proud member of the paypal
mafia
and has seen the intense work ethics of
entrepreneurs like elon musk and peter
thiel first
hand he generally believes that since
there will always be dozens of highly
intelligent and talented teams working
on a given problem
the startup that succeeds will be the
hardest working keith and jason have
battled it out on twitter several times
and i've always found their exchanges
interesting for example in this exchange
jason argues that he himself is evidence
that his work-life balance mentality can
lead to success
he's written several books while running
a profitable company for 18 years
but keith fires back in his typically
brash tone
that 30 million dollar revenue
businesses just aren't particularly
interesting
i think keith has a good point here but
the two are kind of talking past each
other
if you read biographies of elon musk
jeff bezos and really
any of the other massively successful
entrepreneurs you will definitely see
that their work ethics are unparalleled
and the rewards of hard work have been
chronicled in more rigorous detail
in books like grit by angela duckworth
but that doesn't mean that jason is
completely wrong here either
there's certainly nothing wrong with
running a lifestyle business if that's
what your goal
is i'm personally a fan of what naval
ravikon had to say on this issue
in his amazing twitter thread how to get
rich without getting lucky
naval advises entrepreneurs to arm
themselves with specific knowledge
and writes specific knowledge is found
by pursuing your genuine curiosity and
passion
rather than whatever is hot right now
building specific knowledge
will feel like play to you but will look
like work to others
i have completely optimized my career
around building specific knowledge
and it's let me blur the line between
work and life
in a very natural way because startups
require knowledge in so many different
domains
i'm always trying to learn new things
and fortunately
learning never feels like work to me in
fact when i started out i would feel a
bit
guilty and unproductive when i'd spend
hours pouring over a textbook
or watching online classes to learn
something new but it's always paid off
even now a big part of the reason why
i'm making these youtube videos
is to learn about content production so
i can apply that knowledge to my
business
naval says you should be too busy to do
coffee while still keeping an
uncluttered calendar
and i agree with that sentiment
wholeheartedly burnout is real
but i find that for me at least it tends
to set in when i'm spending
all my time on one thing that could
easily be outsourced or automated
fortunately i really love
entrepreneurship and the type of
challenges
it tends to throw at me mark twain
probably said it best
find a job you enjoy doing and you'll
never work a day in your life
so even when i have a crazy week at work
and wind up losing sleep over a
particular problem
i'm still enjoying the process and
that's what's most important